[Music]
[Applause]
all right uh Harold Reynolds joining us
our good buddy MLB network analyst uh
MLB Network's live All-Star coverage
from Seattle gets underway to Eastern
today a red carpet show followed by
intentional talk MLB tonight from
batting practice Harold joins us now on
the program okay we were talking about
what's more impressive winning the slam
dunk contest or Home Run Derby
what would you well first of all Tyreek
Hill if an alligator's afternoon we're
gonna see really how fast he is
no doubt okay so what's more impressive
winning slam dunk or Home Run Derby
well if you're most uh if you're Spud
Webb or somebody like that
I'm going with the dunk
depends on the size
I mean really
the big guys are going to hit home runs
the little guy dunking like that that's
the most impressive well but a little
guy hitting a home run as well
like what's more look how many home runs
did you hit in your life
21 21 okay
that's impressive I could dunk a lot oh
okay all right so what was more
impressive dunking or hitting a home run
I would say Duncan okay
depends on the style I mean just getting
over the Rim Yeah but if you could get
up and like get behind it yeah that's
impressive best picture you homered off
of
oh
um
I don't know Kevin Brown maybe okay
he was throwing the Sinker it didn't
sink and then you took him deep smoked
it
of course of course you did I hope my
voice is hanging in there yeah what's
going on with the The Voice there were
you were you yelling last night
I've been running since I got to Seattle
okay been crazy and then obviously you
know I picked Julio in the home run
there but had the front run yeah front
running all over the place
um no it's been good it's been a good
time really busy I had somebody asked me
this question recently and I had an
answer and then I kept thinking if I had
the right answer what's more impressive
what Bo Jackson did as an athlete or
would show hey uttani is doing as a
baseball player
wow
um these are tough ones
I don't think we'll ever ever see
either one ever again we just won't not
to the level that they're doing it at
but oh Tony is going to catch on Harold
there's going to be players who are
going to want to do both if you're
getting 60 million dollars a year and
you're I mean these guys can do it yeah
but it was funny I was on the set
yesterday with Albert Pujols and Pedro
Martinez
and we were talking about this topic not
Bo Jackson involved but about show hail
Tani
and Pedro put his armor on Albert and he
said basically what you're seeing is
both of us in one person
yeah and we looked at the numbers of
what he's done the first half he's on
Pace for a 50 Homer season
and his era is going to be like Pedro
crazy
never see it again no way guys will try
it they'll never do it at this level
yeah I don't know if he'll ever do it
we're not going to see Bo Jackson again
no no we won't
um
yeah we won't see those two things and
it's amazing we were able to do it yeah
but we won't we won't see it again
talking to Harold Reynolds MLB network
analyst I I'm going to ask you what I
asked Jeff passen of ESPN yesterday
you are Artie Moreno you own the Angels
you've lost nine of ten
what do you do with shoheiotani at the
All-Star break or at the trade deadline
I I think he got I was going to move him
last year
you know okay I just think
he is your Herschel Walker trade
changes the whole franchise
hard to do
people gonna talk about it but you got
to go down to one thing
do you feel like he's gonna resign with
you
if you're gonna resign him great I just
don't think he's going back
and so that's a big gamble you had to
have already had these conversations you
you know it's gonna cost you two players
salaries of a Pedro and an Albert in
current money yeah we're talking five to
seven hundred million dollars are you
gonna pay it
because you're gonna get it back
marketing this guy you can make a
billion dollars in a blank
so are you gonna pay it and that's what
it comes down to it's not do we like him
do we want him back uh uh it's not all
that it's are you gonna pay the freight
and it's really when you sit down you
have a conversation to make the offer if
he's not going to do it you got to move
it yeah but what's the better Avenue to
win because that's what you owe to your
franchise it's just like Portland
Portland with Dame Lillard you owe it to
your fan base to improve your team and
you needed to trade Dame Lillard to
improve your team the angels in Arnie
Moreno you need to decide
can we win with him or do we have a
better chance to win without him
well that's the uniqueness of baseball
you know if you trade Lillard from the
Blazers right one guy can really change
your basketball franchise yes
baseball you have to have
three you have to have two number ones
for sure
and you gotta have a lineup
so shohei is pitching if you decide
you're going to keep him then you got to
go get that other aircraft carrier or
two to get you through to win the whole
thing yeah we already have trout there
yeah that doesn't pitch yeah you know
okay would you trade trout
instead of shohei uttani
at this point in time
I mean if you go again are you going to
sign show hey what if I trade Mike Trout
thinking hey I'm I made a nice move and
you get you're going to get a lot back
from Mike as well but then shohei says
you know what I think I'm gonna be a
Dodger
what now well no I wouldn't well I I saw
where Alex Rodriguez said he would trade
both of them he'd trade trout and shohei
Otani well I mean then you gotta start
all way over I don't know I know you got
to keep one of them
uh
what was it like seeing Ken Griffey Jr
they're back in Seattle
you know what we had a blast he came on
yesterday I've never seen him as engaged
as he was I mean he did the HBCU game on
Friday fantastic great event he was
engaged and yesterday he joined Albert
Pedro myself and Greg am singer and
silver time at Home Run Derby yesterday
right
and in the WBC mookie bets and trout
were like
what's the heading coach walking around
with a glove for where's your bat he
goes I didn't bring my bat and they're
like yeah because you can't hit a home
run no more
so he's like okay he said and this one
got funny Dan he goes all right so I
called my wife Melissa and said hey
bring Lucille to the ballpark it's bad
and so what was that BB King's guitar
yeah wasn't that his guitar yeah I think
so
yeah
so he goes on and says so mookie says
you can't do in 10 swings he says yeah I
can
so he does it in nine all right and so
trout and him are like talking to Junior
and he goes you know that thing's on
autopilot man that bat knows where to go
because there's many nights I just
walked to the plate and Lucille knew
what to do I mean he was talking so much
smack it was fun I wonder if he didn't
get hurt
I know it's part of the game but yeah
like how many home runs would would
Junior have hit
I think it's close to 800. I don't know
if you do the numbers
he was saying 50 a year easy
and he was in his prime
I mean really it's probably just turned
30 and he was already hitting 50 a year
for like three years or two years or
something like that he'd ran off another
three or four at least 40 some
yeah Paulie uh Griffey's last three
years in Seattle 56 homeworks 56 homers
48 homers
question those home runs either no no
because he's not in he he was never
there was never any inkling that Junior
used performance enhancing drugs yeah
yeah he got out
um All-Star game coming up tonight
festivities what's what's the red carpet
show who's going to be on the red carpet
uh Greg i'm singer myself will host
um you know a couple years ago Greg
broke out shorts thinking his legs look
good you know and then all the players
come through it's a fun time uh we'll
talk about the fashion tell you what
baseball players
you know I think Manny Machado started
it about three or four years ago with a
jacket no no shirt on underneath you
know so Mookie Betts has the big hat all
said it changed the whole fashion trend
it was cool man so we'll cover that uh
then all the pre-game and post game all
that on the network obviously the game's
on Fox so it'd be a good time good to
talk to you as always uh get a nap rest
The Voice there for tonight
I'll be ready all right thank you bud
Harold he hit 21 home runs in the show
MLB network analyst